I thought Michael finished this video a
day early and all hell's breaking loose
it's foam man
nerf trick shots
what's going on out there Carmichael I
have something impossible he has
finished a video early for once believe
it or not what are they doing whether
they mess around just taking a break
it's okay just take a break look all
work and no play Jake makes Jack a dull
boy I turn my head for five minutes I
got a cold I've had a cold all week I'm
sick and tired turn my head for two
seconds take it in
[Music]
Oh
classic Jam you just got to go with a
trusty single-shot I survived but I lost
the duel and was trying to be productive
the rules are God has to be between your
legs your hands have to be at your side
because not everyone dies in duels like
I just got wings an avid Euler and I
like to solve my problems out yeah you
shot my paw I challenge you to a duel
that's right I shot your paw I'm the
richest man in town I can do whatever I
want
[Applause]
so we've been working on this anime cart
video for what seems like millions of
years everything in the scene is
rendered speaking of which hey haven't
worn this shirt in a very long time I
have to have contact with the wheel at
all times you know what I'm working them
just like a problem running into is that
I get the scenes all worked out and
ready to render but because they're
really intense scenes they take a really
long time to render even on this
computer which has four GPUs but we've
been running into issues with program
crashes and random other stuff like that
so we're kind of falling behind schedule
on the rendering aspect but that thing
right there it's gonna solve our
problems hope
yo Nick throw me a knife you almost took
out his computer it's not working oh no
wonder this thing is like super dull I
I'm pretty sure I just broke every like
Boy Scout rule on how to handle knives
never cut towards yourself I did it for
a whole year what's in this this my
friend is a computer I love you dude
this is actually gonna be your computer
Nico for all the intense rendering that
you do these days I'm actually taking
this computer for the next couple weeks
while we finish this anime video I'm a
firm believer that computers do not
belong to the person they belonged to
the tasks a computer built for editing
should be used for anybody that needs to
do some heavy editing a computer built
for rendering to be used for anybody
that has render hidden your name brand
gets these other computers its kind of
getting that that's it I'll be on the
computer for a lot my editing and work
you guys want a legit computer puget
hooks it up seriously
they literally interview you about like
what do you intend to do with it and
then they'll run all these benchmarks
after putting it together you're gonna
not lose this like I lost mine
[Music]
you gotta get the blood flowing for all
that rendering you're about to do it's
foam man oh whoa we're looking at the
back of the computer pull it out did you
see this
ready static static forces man just look
at this event those are the feet these
are the legs now the question you must
ask yourself whenever you get a new
computer is how clearly clackety is that
power button satisfactory Oh open up the
side of this is there's a switch puget
employs air cooling for their CPUs
instead of water cooling apparently
these work better cuz it also encourages
air flow throughout the whole system
teach it knows what they're doing
we got one SSD in one our drive kilowatt
power supply four sticks of RAM
the most notable aspect of this rig are
these two devices right here these are
the graphics cards GT X 1080 Ti and I've
got two of them here they're cable
management game is on point we have this
stuff
Michael finished this video a day early
and all hell's breaking loose the bull
shot consecutively Nippo monthly shot
Kiko killed double shot Dan and he was
put on trial for murder because he fired
more than once the only reason he got
off absolutely hos double shot Dan fired
back I'm the grandson to see my grandma
is multiple shots yes I'm here stop that
we should sell mineral rights if I ever
needed but I'm starting a new computer
business okay I'm going to shoot you now
all right let's have a good clean fight
Noda separating you ghosts ready
[Applause]
and shot five times he had a clear shot
he took it he missed he fired again
that's murder we like to have fun around
here but we don't take no dishonourable
duels quiet when I'm talking we shot him
just enough to wound him this time we're
gonna kill him for real we wanted to
keep him alive until we were ready to
all kill him together
I killed my grandpa
back to work back to work it's not a
real explaining that I threw in there
actually I would be perfectly okay if
100% of all spiders were eradicated ya
know like centipedes don't bother me I'd
be down to have like a cinema crawl up
and around my leg I'd be with that
you spider scare right in the Sun did
they spider scare you
Samus I'm in a whole silver ring well
it's gold
- dude mines titanium and iron if you
say the word okay I can't even say it
there's a word Danny what's the word I
can't say that word on camera without
doing push-ups Danny can he's in the
game one ring to rule them all one ring
to find them I thought about getting
that as a tattoo around my wrist yeah
the tattoo that I do have is the Lord of
the Rings quote but where is it said in
the mines of moria how am I glad to see
her instituting a regular exercise
program for all of the people here at
court that was smooth I'll hand that to
you I wasn't aware I even knew which
quote but you did you were thinking like
four levels ahead here in chess who's
going to use this PC well should we call
this PC Amanda Panda no we got it we got
to come up with a cool name for such a
cool computer
Robert obsidian obsidian I like it
few things are more satisfying than
coming in mourning after a render to see
that it's been finished it worked
yeah the new computer works great news I
did a test so there's a lot of green
screen shots in this video and you got
to put something in the background there
that's not you know green so the cars
are driving through this area right I
just basically made a new camera and
pointed it backwards and just rendered
out 300 frames of that no it's the same
thing as if you're just up stick a
camera out of the back of a car and just
drive down a road so I rendered that
first shot of it aiming backwards or
under that on Sam's computer and then I
basically just took that same camera and
I rotated it 90 degrees for the side
view shots we can just put that there
and I rendered out with the exact same
settings the exact same sequence length
and we can see how long it took to
render it on this computer versus Sam's
computer so this first shot I started at
2:13 p.m.
and it ended at 5:30 a.m. let's say 2:30
to 5:30 15 hours not too bad now let's
look at the second shot from 717 p.m. to
313 a.m. 8 hours
that's straight up hat that's great
that's great news Sam needs to get back
here this is the Pug B jacket the Pug B
I have pug B but I've only played like
three games player unknown gravitational
bias hug B